guess what time it is it's time to wrap
the presents it's Christmas so obviously
the best time to wrap is on Christmas
we're gonna play a little bit of play
Michael Buble hmm that's not right
plain Michael Buble shuffle that song
close enough it's beginning to look a
lot like Grandma Maddie's but I want you
to be in the movie it's beginning to
look a lot like because it is Christmas
and you can peek in the presents because
basically like we're rocking it
Joe what's wrong I don't want to be in
the film play Michael Buble would you
did you specify Christmas Michael Buble
there's only Michael a bit that's all I
am
you know I think I could actually be
good at it don't you try hmm look I got
suitcase yeah put anything inside just a
I'll put something inside I don't know
wall happy is my big day
whoa what's a marinara this one you
didn't you know I didn't know so we sat
at Bloomingdale's looking at it for an
hour
oh my god you don't know she was in
there really good a lot oh you're being
such a good little boy so now it is time
for our Christmas Eve Krita no it's
christmas now it's christmas love
Christmas Day dinner I said we got a
little surprise in the mail we have a
Lenovo yoga 2 Lenovo yoga pro 2 Lenovo
yoga pro 2 so it's awesome
is what it is it is this it's God you
can you can use it as a projector on the
side of you guys have probably seen the
commercials I saw a bunch of them not
sponsored at all I I'm gonna go put some
Christmas pictures on there so that we
can have a little projector light show
with our new toy I've got my sweater on
hey mr. Raman hmm and Bill was on his
way back from the lines right
yeah he'll be real sleepy it better not
worn out he was sleeping at dinner so I
think we're gonna be all right oh here
it is what yours the box yoga tablet 2
Oh like I said it all look at little
Jenna oh okay this is pretty cool this
is great this is great
alright let's see let's keep going
better not show each other phones I know
look at winners oh we know reenactment
let's hear her I shoes all right should
you know what these pictures like least
your bangs are real straight look at
that blonde hair so yeah actually real
damn Oh have those two don't you put in
the milk I still do the head see God we
know it's laughing oh sure with me my
face course were like this because I
turn around you're a stir basket or
something Oh
give me that picture yeah Jenna is
hammered papa
okay guys so this I preordered back in
February and it finally shipped its the
cannon and began an end to is basically
like that old one that I had but it does
this flips all the way up okay you
that's me that's you
hmm the video on this one so we're gonna
switch from this video now to this one
so this one right here is the canon n
way to both the rel canonical ii like
your eyes are both from the same family
this one is the canon n 2 gives a little
square and this one's the canon and 100
mm-hmm
he's me feet feet here's my face here's
my face how's the audio how's the audio
mm-hmm
hey Bri is that us Briana Briana she
wait do I kill me do I see myself on the
camera I think you're a boy I bet I do
haha guys I'm tap dancin like this I
look like children of the corn I told
you did y know she took classes yeah
shuffle step did not take shook her step
up the lair and she was old enough look
at me you would look at that shucks yeah
I like you getting into it you gotta get
the tongue out right finds another pause
to back up yeah you had a move you back
was 1990 look at me my Mario my my am
nightgown mr. Miyamoto I met you two 910
well gotta get doing math 24 years later
this Easter what do we just having like
a random basket hiding time